[Musique]
la ville de Québec abrite de nombreux
lieux historiques parmi eux on compte la
plus vieille église du pays préservée
depuis sa construction au XVIIe siècle
mais quel âge a-t-elle exactement c'est
ce que des experts ont récemment tenté
de découvrir
c'est un joyau méconnu de notre
patrimoine dans la base ville de Québec
cachée derrière ses murs de pierre
l'église Notre-Dame des Anges
c'est l'église du monastère des
Augustines
[Musique]
tous les jours les sœurs s'y retrouvent
pour la messe
ce bâtiment c'est la plus vieille église
du pays or des analyses récentes faites
dans sa charpente laisse croire qu'elle
pourrait être encore plus vieille qu'on
le croyait c'est l'idée qui anime Denis
Robitaille chargée de projet au
monastère et passionné d'histoire cette
église que nous avons de sous les yeux
que survécu toutes ces années est-elle
celle de 1671 est-elle celle de 1620 ce
qui serait extraordinaire la réponse
dans la charpente
[Musique]
autour de 1620 à la demande de Samuel de
Champlain les frères Récollets
construisent près de la rivière
Saint-Charles un couvent et une église
mais leur projet est interrompu neuf ans
plus tard par la prise de Québec par des
Anglais les frères
dans le conseil 1670 surviennent et à
cette époque là quand il revient leur
église leur couvent être bien mauvais
état parce que pas été entretenu tout ce
temps-là et ils doivent reconstruire les
soeurs Augustine s'installeront dans les
lieux en 1693 après le départ des
Récollets
au fil du temps elles ont fait ériger
d'autres bâtiments dont un hôpital dans
l'enceinte de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'hôpital général de Québec
désormais camouflé dans ce complexe
l'Église a toujours été considéré comme
datant du retour des Récollets en
Nouvelle-France il y a 350 ans
mais en 2008 des analyses faites dans la
charpente du toit ont révélé que
certaines pièces de bois étaient plus
anciennes elles ont plus de 400 ans
l'église pourrait donc être plus vieille
alors quand on a appris que il y avait
des pièces de 1618 c'est presque
inimaginable de penser qu'un bâtiment
est survécu aussi longtemps quand on a
découvert ça on se dit mais il faut
absolument creuser
[Musique]
pour en avoir le cœur net c'est toute
une équipe qui s'engouffre sous les
combles parmi eux l'architecte Émile
Gilbert faut aller faire seul endroit
sur le moins visible possible je suis à
chercher les clés dans les femmes pour
savoir à quand remonter réellement la
charpente il faut d'abord déterminer de
quoi elle est faite
en 2008 deux prélèvements ont été faits
sur des pièces en pin qui se sont
révélées datées de 1618 mais comme rien
ne ressemble plus à une poutre en bois
qu'une autre poutre en bois il faut
maintenant vérifier si tout l'ouvrage
est fait en pin au microscope
ils vont être capable d'identifier
exactement ce que j'ai prélevé dans leur
laboratoire de l'Université Laval Martin
Simard et Anne deloued vont déterminer
de quelle essence de bois il s'agit une
étape essentielle avant de pouvoir
déterminer son âge grâce à la
dendrochronologie l'étude des cernes de
croissance des arbres
pendant sa vie un arbre croit en hauteur
et en largeur chaque année un nouveau
cernes de croissance s'ajoute à son
tronc la largeur de ce CERN varie en
fonction du climat une année faste
donnera un cerne large une saison plus
rude un Cernay 3 et puisque le climat va
affecter plusieurs arbres dans la même
région on a le même signal climatique et
la plupart des arbres du même espèce
vont montrer les mêmes variations d'une
année à l'autre dans la largeur de leur
cerve un peu comme des codes barres les
chercheurs superposent les cernes de
croissance des arbres d'une même espèce
pour les comparer en partant d'arbres
abattus à une date connue ils peuvent
constituer une série d'échantillons qui
leur permet de remonter dans le temps et
là on va comparer notre notre
échantillon qui est d'âge inconnu on
veut le comparer tout le long de cette
série là et voir cette typiquement à
quel endroit les patrons de croissance
de notre échantillon
sans les mieux corrélés c'est une
méthode éprouvée mais dans le cas de
l'église du monastère des Augustines les
chercheurs vont tomber sur un os sont
petites puisque tu vois des tracker
la majeure partie de la charpente n'est
pas en
painette le hic ce qui n'existe aucune
référence des anneaux de croissance de
l'épinette pour la région de Québec ils
n'ont donc rien pour comparer les
échantillons il y a eu des séries qui
ont été faites à la limite des arts mais
évidemment puisqu'on est dans des zones
climatiques différentes on peut pas s'en
servir
[Musique]
retour à la case départ à l'église
Notre-Dame des Anges
en attendant de trouver des références
pour les peanuts l'équipe va quand même
prélever une série d'échantillons dans
les pièces de la charpente
il faut choisir les bons endroits ici on
dirait que c'est vraiment la surface
d'origine ce qu'on veut c'est d'avoir
les derniers cernes que l'arbre produit
avant d'être coupé les endroits
peut-être dans les coins où est-ce que
il resterait de l'écorce c'est sûr que
s'il reste l'écorce c'est un signe
vraiment clair que le poids on a le
dernier cerne
[Musique]
les chercheurs prélèvent des carottes de
bois perpendiculaires aux anneaux de
croissance en essayant de s'approcher le
plus possible du cœur de l'arbre lors de
notre carotte donc les courbures des
centres de croissance nous indiquent
qu'on était près du centre de l'arbre de
la moelle de l'arbre de toute façon ce
qui nous intéresse nous c'est d'avoir la
plus longue séquence de scène
de retour au laboratoire Anne deloued
analyse les échantillons au microscope
elle mesure scrupuleusement chaque
cernes au micromètre près les données
sont ensuite ajustées pour pouvoir
comparer les arbres entre eux
pour enlever les effets qui sont pas
climatiques en fait les effets supposant
d'une trouée dans une forêt qui aura
avantagé la croissance d'un arbre donc
on va enlever ces variations là qu'on
veut pas retenir en fait mais le
problème reste entier sans série de
référence pour les pinèdes à quoi
comparer ses échantillons pour
déterminer leur âge
[Musique]
je pense qu'on est bientôt arrivé
la solution va apparaître dans
Charlevoix
au bord du fleuve Saint-Laurent dans une
autre église celle du village de Saint
Irénée
c'est un église qui a été construite en
1842 tout en bois et presque tout en
charpente d'épinettes et cette séquence
là ici mais quand on parle de 18,42 ça
veut dire que le bois c'est le bois qui
était abattu un bois mature donc vous
vous reculez ça ou 150 ans pour l'âge du
bois et c'est la période principale qui
nous manquait pour établir cette
séquence là
les combles sont moins accessibles qu'au
monastère des Augustines
mais le jeu en vaut la chandelle les
carottes prélevées ici pourraient être
le chaînon manquant entre des épinettes
vivantes de nos jours et celles abattu à
l'époque des Récollets alors on va
espérer ici que si on a réussi à avoir
des arbres assez vieux on va réussir à
tranquillement aller vers le passé et
rallonger notre série de cernes de
l'épinette
[Musique]
les chercheurs ont analysé le bois de
l'église de Saint Irénée mais aussi
d'autres bâtiments de la région en tout
51 épinettes de différentes époques ils
ont pu créer une série temporelle qui
remontent à 1483 la série de référence
au début elle est malheureusement pas
très loin dans le temps puisque c'était
des herbes vivants qui provenaient du
Chesnay et on avait les échantillons
adaptés de l'église de l'hôpital général
donc on a commencé par l'église de cette
sirénée qui est adaptée à 1844 et
ensuite on a été échantillonné l'aile de
la première île de la communauté de
l'hôpital général à ce moment-là dont la
date de construction était de 737
donc c'est ce qui nous a permis de
combler la série au complet dans le cas
des échantillons de l'église on avait eu
on a réussi à avoir une très bonne
correspondance une corrélation très
forte entre ces échantillons là et la
série de référence donc c'est ce qui
nous permet d'avoir une très grande
certitude dans les dates qu'on a obtenu
ces dates les voici
l'essentiel de la charpente de l'église
Notre-Dame-des-Anges en épinettes et de
1671 un petit pincement pour ceux qui
s'était pris à rêver une église de 400
ans
soulagé enfin on peut avancer on sait où
on s'en va on connaît la vérité
maintenant l'histoire qui nous a été
rapportée est à donc exact
mais alors comment expliquer que
quelques pièces en pin est 50 ans de
plus pour Émile Gilbert c'est simple
alors retour en Nouvelle France les
récoller ont récupéré des éléments
encore utilisables dans leur église
abandonnée ils ont récupéré ce qu'il
pouvait du moins il y en avait tant qui
voulaient mais des bras pour le couper
pour travailler puis de mettre en place
il y en avait pas beaucoup vraiment pas
donc de trouver des pièces de
récupération c'était précieux donc ils
ont récupéré ce qui était valable
n'empêche il y aurait un peu de la
première église des Récollets dans celle
qui a survécu jusqu'à nous ce bâtiment
doit survécu donc en partie puisqu'on
retrouve des charpentes de cette époque
là depuis du tout début depuis que
Champlain aurait élevé Québec jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
un élément de plus dans l'histoire d'une
vieille dame d'âge vénérable comme celle
qui la fréquente encore religieusement
[Musique]